[Music]
foreign
thinking about this the other day when
because i was like i'm going to do a
podcast
where we don't talk about the comments
section i feel like comedians it always
comes up
and i was listening to one of your
podcasts and you had such a poignant
um take on it where you you know like
respond to people
sometimes and i was thinking about that
and i was like oh because i just
auto block comments so i never have to
see them and pretend they're not there
but then i'll do someone else's podcast
like segora burst and then i'll just see
the one that is you know or whatever and
how to keep that negativity out but i
think in the last maybe it's just the
pandemic or
how few problems that you know you
realize you have as you get older and
you see what's going on in the world and
that you have no right to complain about
anything
um i realized i was like you know what i
would actually rather be polarizing
than just me i'd rather if you like me i
want you to love me
if you don't like me i want you to hate
me i've been doing that sometimes on
purpose i
like to cook people like oh you're so
sweet and so funny and you're
blah blah blah and so then sometimes i'm
like you never know what i'm doing like
sometimes i'm just trolling stuff or
things because people got real excited
when i was like oh
outcast is better than the beatles
people were like oh look at this guy
he's so progressive on the right side of
here
history and then i made another tweet
being like oh if you're going to a
regular season baseball game and taking
a day off work you're probably a fucking
loser
why are you going to a regular season
baseball game oh bad take bro baseball's
great dude
i'm like yeah i don't give a fuck either
way yeah like i'm just saying
stuff but if there's this thing that
happened whereas like comedians
we're supposed to be dangerous we're
supposed to say things that no one else
will say where it's sort of like
uh uh we're courageous for a living like
you're coming to see like a delusional
amount of confidence
on a take and i always say like it's not
our job to be right
ever or you know it's i i think we say
something that's like
kind of indefensible and then we have to
defend it with jokes and try to convince
you and at the end we might be like oh
that didn't work but we're taking you on
like some journey
yeah and we don't have to be right we're
not scientists we're not doctors i think
we all forgot that in the pandemic yeah
you poke holes at the truth you poke
holes at things that you see
and you you present your argument as
like a
like a lawyer or like anyone but it's
not my job to be the judge
it's not my job to go like this is right
or this is wrong
like you know if the audience isn't
loving the joke like of course i'll
adjust
on the thing but like as far as being
like well you
have to i think that's been shift before
we've talked about this before like a
shift in
how people have stopped writing to
surprise and have started
writing to be agreed with can i tell and
this is
why i i like miss doing stand-ups so
much at either the comedy store or just
like a club that has a lineup you're on
it
you know scores on it rogan's on it
whoever's on it because um
when you're only performing to your fans
they're gonna maybe give you a little
like going on stage when people are
coming to see you
and then me having to win them over
that's when you get good there's this
sort of epidemic of clapter happening
where someone will be like
you know um you know so who voted for by
and i was like
and then it's like yeah fuck trump woo
and it's like those weren't jokes
that was this is now a rally
like we're going for the involuntary
laughter
and i and i must say i remember a time
at the improv where you went on stage
and
you you kill in a way that i just i
don't
think like you have to see you lie i
mean
seeing you live you kill in a way that's
like
frustrating like because it's like
it the building shakes i mean you kill
in a way that inspires me and
i watch you perform in the way you surf
the laughs and the way that you're so
patient and let them come to you like
you were just saying
and um i just am curious if you always
had that
that cadence and that patience on stage
i sort of have like a desperation that i
have to get to a thing and it's
taken me so long to be able to let them
come to me
um i think it's something that's been
ingrained in me from like
just issues of the child you know where
i'm like
i moved around a lot i moved around from
chicago to oregon and stuff and and just
learning that like i had to defend what
i enjoyed i've been
a pro wrestling fan my whole life and
people this is stupid so i learned it
very early on and be like oh i don't
need you
to agree with me like i don't know you
know what you're in a
company with the one rick rubin easily
the biggest music producer on the planet
all he watches is uh wrestling yeah so
you're in good company
i know smart people love wrestling in 90
day fiance
and wrestling is so fascinating to me
because
it's oddly very feminist
and it's fun to watch people fight
without having to worry someone's going
to die
thank you so much that's all i've been
trying to say
it's not like the nfl which is kind of
just like fancy slavery at this point
you know it's like um you know it's like
i don't have to
i mean the nfl draft is just like
watching
you know these men go up and get these
pr like it's just
it just feels like um mma i'm just like
oh no
yeah like that might kill each other
when they you're like he's already down
you're hitting them some more i like
knowing they're friends at the end
they're just trying to put on a
performance
for me and i'm not uh worried that i'm
participating in some cte
situation like i'm not like enabling
some really well wrestling's got his own
thing with that from the past
and things so that's doing better now
the wrestlers
that because they do choreograph it and
orchestrate it right
and it's all fun history just this past
weekend they had the very first
two black women headlined their biggest
event of the year
never happened before i never thought
i'd see it
and it did and it was a great match and
they kicked ass it was wonderful
and i appreciate it thank you sasha
banks if it wasn't for you
i wouldn't have my own signature sneaker
thank you
what age did you first start watching it
uh like hulk hogan day
yeah yeah oh yeah for sure yeah like uh
yeah that's like my first
my uncle because i you know grew up with
just my mom my sister my aunt
house full of ladies and my uncle would
take me to chicago to rosemont horizon
go see wwf house shows and i'd see hulk
hogan
and stretcher matches the ultimate
warrior there's also something so
um you know there's this big
conversation about toxic masculinity
which
you know is is such a complicated topic
to get into but um there it's pretty the
guys are feminine the women are
masculine like it's just very like the
women are
i mean just seeing such strong muscular
women
you know when i saw that and then men
that were wearing little
things that were kind of feminine and
they were shiny and had long hair
there's a whole even bigger world going
on right now there's sunny kiss
and sunny kids is amazing because sunny
kiss wears straight up booty diva shorts
identifies as whatever you want to call
them male female he hers just says
whatever you see me as is what i
am and then just goes out there and
kicks ass this is amazing and it's also
comedy yeah you know they're trying to
make you laugh they're trying to like
you know we're joking have you been out
there have you been on tour at all since
i just started i just booked some days
and going salt lake city in may
that'd be my first one back out since um
denver
in november so i just you know they've
been around here did a couple shows with
you
did a couple uh the magic castle parking
lot show
which i was like oh man we've really
fallen when we are begging to perform at
the feet of magicians
so dark too so dark that's not the
the industry i knew do you like the car
shows which is like no
i don't either i don't like clackers
it's against everything
in my like i'm just being taught to the
hate honks
cracking or people yelling at me from
cars of any nature
that's right yeah i mean yeah it's like
it's like oh i associate honks with like
being cat called being yeah like it's
just such a
uh jarring uh response instead of
laughter but i also
did a bunch of car shows when i was so
desperate to do something i was so
afraid i was getting like so rusty
at stand up or i would forget how to do
it or something or
um be out of touch or whatever my a
million fears were i was going to fall
behind
if i can go on and on but when i did
them i also felt like i was developing
bad habits
all these habits this is what you're
timing all these habits i worked so hard
to break i started like
yelling i started going really fast i
was like doubting myself it was just
like
i just it really was not yeah i had the
same
uh fears and struggle but i was like
first of all i can't book
uh the driving gigs i'm not people
aren't gonna come see me for that like
they would you
a bird and secondly i was like at some
point
i would at the oh i remember the points
when i did some mushrooms
and then they told me to be nimble like
a bunny and i was like hey
just fuck it like you know fuck it like
i'll if i'm rusty i'll rusty i'll get
good again
later like and then i found out from
not doing it for a few months and then
doing it once where i was like oh i'm
actually kind of
still good and even in some ways i'm
like necessarily better because i'm not
in rhythm but i'm like
oh i feel more in the moment i feel
growth
so in some ways i was like oh i'm happy
i feel
me not doing it for like six seven
months like i'm not even writing jokes
i'm not even doing
anything i'm just like but i feel like
it's probably going to extend my career
by like 10 years because i got this
break to just
go and do voice acting go and um
focus i took some singing lessons just
acting classes more and more
auditions and just being like oh that
just i'm not going to beat my head
against the wall
on that because even when i'm doing it
i'm not having fun
i'm scared we take advan i i just really
think
i was taking it for granted before i was
like i gotta work on this joke i gotta
work on this joke you know and
and missing it a little bit was because
if you have a great joke if you're not
excited about it or grateful to be on
stage it's not gonna kill the way that
it should like
it's like it's just not fun and it was
also just
been realizing reclaiming my power in
that regard of like
like still have having real life fear of
like what was going to happen
was what what my life going to be about
am i going to see my niece
you know who you know was just born and
and i was like why don't
give a fuck what netflix thinks of me
why don't you give a fuck
oh i think about when you're 12
like you did everything like you got a
special you're on show
you did everything you wanted to do so
if you never get another special
fuck it like just have fun
and ever since i've been thinking about
that it's been so much more fun for me
because i'm not like
worried about what other people are
doing and it's hard to maintain i lose
it well here's the thing i think i do
think
you know and and i want to talk about
your podcast because you get really
granular into the nitty-gritty about
sort of mental health things and you
know insecurities and things that a lot
of people are afraid to share
or or can't necessarily verbalize in an
eloquent way and you have this
incredible way of just saying something
talking about either insecurities or you
know you know um starting conversations
about these really sticky mental health
things that you know
um you're just you're just brilliant at
it um and uh and i do
feel like the only way i was able to
really
deal with my workaholism was because and
constantly comparing ourselves to others
which is sometimes healthy like a
healthy competition is good they did it
i can do it too it's not like i'm
full of game yeah it's just sort of like
oh like sometimes it drives you and
sometimes
it's a liability and eats you alive and
is unhealthy and
you know a sick addiction to resentment
and competition or whatever
or this person doesn't deserve it or you
start to get into that i deserve it
whatever
um but i do think that it i could only
really face it and look at it
when no one else was when everyone was
on the bench
because it's it was like we're all be
okay we're all taking we're all not
doing this no one's achieving anything
right now great
like we can finally look at who we want
to be and what do i actually want to
talk about when i'm not just trying to
beat this person to a special like what
do i who do i actually want to be when
i'm not like
i gotta i gotta go up three times this
week girls people are gonna think i'm
not doing it like all my ego
broke away yeah it's one of the bit i
mean you know from
doing tarot cards in the past like
there's a card i would get sometimes
like about oppression
and i would and i'd be like this fucking
guard sucks and then but then you'd read
about him like oh there's
positives to being oppressed um you
don't want to
be oppressed for your life but there's
sometimes there's positive to be locked
in place
because it forces you to like think your
way out of things it forces you to slow
down
because if you're locked in place if
you're like fuck around you're gonna
break your shit you're gonna fuck
yourself over by thrashing around
you have to like calm down and really
uh embrace whatever is going on in that
moment to really
just slow your mind down a bit and
that's been what i've been trying to do
while also at the same time
being like um more aware of my value
yes and now just take i i really i was
talking with
kristen my assistant before governor
just about um i've reached this point in
acting now that i reached a stand-up
before where i was like oh i can like
i can say no i cannot i can say no to
offers
like before it was like oh like maybe
i'll say no to an audition
no i'm not going to tell you you're
offering it to me
yeah oh no way i'm saying no and then if
i say no
you're never going to ask me again when
in reality the more you say no the more
they want you which is so
you know but it's all gonna go away my
agent's not gonna like me anymore and
they're not gonna even
like the fear that sets in saying no
to a bad job that's not not even
after scale the fear that comes up
uh how dare i you know by the time you
pay agent manager in taxes you're making
you know
eighty dollars and it's five days and
you have to bring your own wardrobe and
i say no and i'm like
everything's over everyone's gonna hate
me the casting director is gonna hate me
how fast
i go to that when in reality they're
like good for her for passing on this
she has self-respect all of a sudden
when did that start i know
well it's gonna start for me next week
[Laughter]
i mean the fact that you say i mean you
work more than anyone you're like
the busiest person i know even during
the pandemic and i want to ask you
uh because the big insecurity that's set
in during the pandemic for me
of like am i doing what everyone else is
doing are people getting ahead or
whatever
insecure shit going on is social media
like how did your relationship with
social media change because
i think i needed some time to be forced
to do ig lives and forced to take social
media more seriously like how
did your relationship change um i just
was bringing a balance back to it
because i think um
i was way too into it especially when i
was single and stuff and could just
focus on
working and that was it and then when i
got with my wife who's very
not into social media that much at all
like she could make a lot of money
if you've seen her she could be the
biggest
uh influencer on instagram she would
eclipse kim kardashian real quick
just one bikini photo and you could
retire but whatever
could i please manage her she's
literally the hottest woman i've
ever seen thank you she'll love hearing
this
but well also she's so kind and
intelligent as well
yeah but her ass though is wild
it truly i mean it is switches it is so
it does i watch it sometimes i carry it
up the stairs for her
i'm like this has got to be a load on
you i got to care
it is a legitimate caboose
but yeah we'll get back to your wife's
body in a second and i have a lot of
questions about her
but i feel like we kind of blew past a
couple things i'd like to dig into more
um because you have so much wisdom you
know in this area i'd like to talk about
the tarot
cards because i know nothing about tarot
cards and i'd like to talk about
mushrooms because i've never done
mushrooms in my life really you seem
like you've done all the drugs
because okay in
quarantine i did go a little off the
rails i am
i want to say like 15 days off of weed
edibles
because they didn't work for like the i
can do the faces have to stop because
then i i mean they just double edged
because then i'm eating on top of it and
then
i wake up and i'm like i feel so chubby
and i hate it and then i place another
order
so i guess compared to your wife's ass
you
are will always be minuscule
did you just marry her so you could feel
like a tiny little
whisper of a thing i'm the little spoon
you look
anorexic
like how does she buy pants like i'm not
i'm actually not joking she i mean the
times i've seen her she's been in like a
stretchy dress and i've heard general
outfit
cause like she can't what else could she
wear she struggles yeah
pants poor thing i feel awful for you
but she does get people fall you know
the other day somebody
followed her on her walk you know
yelling at the
car out at her you know just because it
happened
to be fair not to defend a cat caller
but i would definitely
i definitely have followed her a little
bit just to be like is that like i'm
fascinated and i was like stop stop bad
whitney bad whitney bad
so tell me about the mushroom experience
like what is the
um is it more to do like like
medicinally like do you have a purpose
going in or is it more to kind of check
out and be creative
it's a little bit of both um basically
um if you've never done mushrooms it
kind of feels like i tried i just
didn't i did like lsd like i think tabs
when i was like 11.
i'm like i don't do drugs i mean i do
lsd like just tabs from strangers in
delaware
i just like doing a check-in for myself
the best way i could describe it is that
like
i feel like my regular life is that i'm
a you know
rattling a little maze and then when i
do mushrooms sometimes a little hand
comes out grabs me by my collar
pulls me up so i can see where the exit
is and see where all the cheese is and
not be afraid of everything and then it
lets me go and drops me back in and i
have to try to remember
those things um so it's like i don't try
to do it too much but i've had
so many wonderful experiences from from
doing mushrooms i
um do alone or with someone usually with
people
sometimes alone the last one because
with the
the last one yeah i was just in my house
at two in the morning
uh locked in my office so i wouldn't
scare my wife even though she
she eventually found out because i
started stumbling around imagine if you
hallucinated on mushrooms and her butt
got bigger
i mean
okay no heat greedy but i asked because
this i actually have an insecurity
uh with you uh when i came on
the show undateable that uh you
obviously were on and i came on like as
a guest it was like such a weird
experience but um
i was like so insecure the whole time
and and you know when you go into
someone else's show and everybody's
friends that everyone's got a thing and
you come on and you like you know
um are like trying to be friends with
everyone or trying to you like don't
know any inside jokes and you're just
sort of like don't know the drill
and you're the outsider or whatever and
um
and i think it was like after show or
something and you'd smoke some weed
and i was like are you stoned like i was
such a dork
and you were like yeah and i was like oh
what's the highlight and you're like
well you're kind of ruining it
like it's not fun anymore and i was like
oh
like i was just like trying to talk to
you and be like what's your high like
man and you were like dude please stop
and i was like okay got it like of
course
because i'm so fat i would like to be
able to uh
learn how to chill out not be so manic
and you know i'm just trying to find a
way to
different strokes yeah folks though like
if you try it and you don't love it
it's not for you but because i've never
tried to force it and you know
i'm like cheech or chong which one was
it
chong yeah i was always like smoke
everybody's movie maybe even babies i'm
like even babies
i heard they don't get along or talk i
could see that i love that i'm just
starting shit
like just like i don't know that either
one but i met i met
one of them and i could see not getting
along with them
i remember i i wrote on that do you
remember tbs
did a roast of chichen chang and i
remember
ralphie may went up and killed so hard
and was so funny
but there was like a scrap between him
and i think once like it got real like a
roast is never supposed to get real it's
like we're all joking we're doing this
for money
like you get it just you know and it got
heated for real
because i think the one thing was don't
come after ralphie's weight or something
and someone did and you know
it was just um well that seems like that
like you can't call that one there's a
lot of things you could call
but you can't be like well we can't talk
about your weight
[Laughter]
that's crazy
i might be like we're playing baseball
but you can't use the
[Laughter]
yeah well it was everyone has their own
thing that they come with that is off
limits
but it's usually the person being
roasted like david hasselhoff
it was you can't come after uh
well that's the thing about the burger
was that him
no that was definitely him what was
david hasselhoff's uh
i think well hulk hogan was there and he
said i'll only do it if you don't talk
about my daughter
which i thought was badass uh uh shatner
was don't talk about his dead wife who
drowned in his pool that seems
appropriate
we went so hard at it um
and then uh uh tommy lee on pam anderson
road says you can't talk about the dead
kid in the pool because there was
like it's usually like tragedies like
that yeah that makes sense snoop dogg
was like you can't talk about my rest
like i mean usually it's stuff like that
and every now and then someone will come
with something it's like okay we can't
not
like bob saget saying don't talk about
the olsen twins it was like okay that's
cute
uh you know it's like it's trying to
find that line of
you know are people gonna be distracted
by not bringing up this elephant the
living room and how do we do it in a way
that's not
uh hurting them but still honoring your
request
or then we'll just cut it out later or
whatever but i remember that was someone
crossed the line and it got
it got real and that's so interesting to
me when comedians where all we do is
you know um uh roast each other all day
and then you get your feelings hurt all
of a sudden there's always you realize
well i'm hoping for that i'm a person
i'm sensitive
because i'm an actor too i gotta be
sensitive
uh and i just i get that because
if i don't respect you if i don't
respect you in your comedy then i
definitely don't want you saying
something about me i think those are the
things that
are missing some of the times right when
you're just getting random people and
it's like i don't i didn't come up with
you i don't
and i'm not like i have to come up with
you yeah you don't know me like i don't
know you for you to be talking to me
like that yeah
like you know and so i get that that's
why my you know
issue no but i've solved them because
i've just never been a big fan of the
roast
because i was like oh i like these old d
martin rose oh they didn't really know
each other that well either so that's
fine
well and you did a show that was like
kind roasting mm-hmm
yeah which is true yeah which is such a
cool take
like such a fresher take i think it was
just made it fun
and it's harder it makes people work
different muscles of their
mind which i'm always pro cause it's
just i mean just all you know
simple easier to destroy than create
yeah and you just can't go for the
low-hanging fruit which is like i feel
like we're at a time where it's like
time to
like cut it out with the low-hanging
fruit like that easy shit
that's what i'd like to talk about what
do you think cause we talked about
before people
writing to be agree with what do you
think is coming new because i think it
is feeling good for me because i feel
like people want to get silly again
and that's when i shine well well i
think that your comedy is
is is like um you know they say the one
stock that never
uh is affected by the economy or
anything that's going on in the news is
krispy kreme
swear to god like it just always is like
solid like you to me i i don't feel like
to me mean comedians in the last four
years
people are just not into because there
was so much meanness all the time
on twitter and with our president and
you would just constantly see nastiness
so i do think your comedy
you know was a respite in that time but
i also think now people can go
you know see a comedy show and just be
silly and not be like we need to
you know change the world in this next
two hours you know um
but i i it's interesting because i feel
like
this last four years you know
something like me like there is a thing
where you're like okay
what's my responsibility right now with
a platform
like what should i be more political
should i do does anyone want to hear
from me
like i think i just i get a little
fraught with that i think just with the
last four years there's just a little
bit of like
do i need to teach should might do i
need to like tell stories
that help change people's minds about
things you know like i feel a little bit
of like
pressure to say more sometimes or or
i could understand that with you because
you that's you're in a pr
people consider a privileged position
and so then you feel
a weight to that um i was feeling a
little bit not necessarily a way to just
a change i'm like like oh i'm
becoming a different comedian and i was
like oh what
it's kind of that similar story and then
my friend gabe he was
like uh he just gave me the best advice
and now that's where i've been my focus
is he's like
i was like i just don't feel like you
know i'm getting older my son's like
gonna be 18.
uh you know i'm thinking about having
another kid and and all these things and
i'm like i don't feel like
i can't sell this like pothead and she
was like you never that's not what you
sold you're like you're not
selling because you sell being yourself
you sell being free
he's like you sell freedom is your is
it's your style and i'm like oh that
opened
my mind more where i was just like i
could just say whatever the fuck i want
because
that's what i'm supposed to do and i
think especially at this time
when it's supposed to be either i'm
supposed to be worried about
being murdered by police or i'm supposed
to
uh if i'm not worried about it i should
be out there protesting about it
um you know i'm doing the chop 420 show
and i had a lady
reach out to me and be like how dare you
host this show
while our brothers and sisters are
locked in jail for marijuana
and i was like don't you get don't you
get that
that's what this show's supposed to make
you feel it's like how ridiculous that
not
that i shouldn't have a show is that
these laws shouldn't be like that
if this is going on this is ridiculous
it's stupid
and that's what i'm selling you the
dream of that future you want so why the
fuck are you yelling at me
yeah and so many people are in so much
pain right now and i don't know
how i'd behave be behaving if i was just
a
fan on social media like yeah that's so
true i'm
i'm sure i'd be like you need to fuck
this post i'm sure i would be the
biggest troll
on the planet if i wasn't a public
person i forget that sometimes i had to
delete a thing because i had another
like oh retweeted something about
charles barkley and this is like
i bet she's a fan of you she might be
watching this podcast uh this white lady
this 20-ish 30-ish white lady just was
like
he's on because he was just basically
being like quit being so republican
democrat when they're both selling
uh against our best interests you know
you got to look at a bigger thing and
then
she was like he's doing this you know
both side ism
she's being basically being an uncle tom
and i was like oh first of
all you can't say that you're a white
lady you can't call
anybody uncle tom i'm not going to
accept that not even your uncle tom no
no no
yeah it's a gym he's not going to jam
now switching oh too close to jim crow
he's uncle jeff
and then secondly it's just a thing or
go like it took me a step back and go
like oh
wait like why do i engage with some of
these things when people
just are fucking stupid or they're
committed
you know they're not committed to
changing their minds like
they're not interested in changing their
minds and i think that happens a lot
when people are in fear you know they
say that
um when you're in fear your iq level
goes down like 10 points we
actually get stupider when we're scared
like in the pandemic we just saw it
happen people were scared of dying and
they just got
dumber he just bought toilet paper and
uh yeah totally
and it's interesting because comedians
like it's kind of
i don't in like i'm so insecure maybe
it's an insecurity thing like
i want to be wrong like because then
you're not if you're right already like
you know everything like you know like
you're just done learning
you know it's so wild to me that you
know people are just like
nope i got it my point of views are
stuck forever
this is what i believe and i'm only
going to look for the things that
reinforce my own beliefs
and malign anyone that you know
disagrees with me
yeah and leave with all emotion with no
fact when it's just like
you're prisoner of that moment over one
thing that charles barkley said to the
point that you would call him
uncle tom when he's like well like do
you know
how he's donated millions to black
colleges
you know how he's done also right now
yeah
it doesn't even matter what he's done
you're absolutely right
but it's like you're such an idiot that
to even bring
like you're you're on the wrong side
you're you're fighting against your own
allies
but what makes me what fascinates me
about that is i'm like you
truly like you put this in writing like
you
you have so many you ran that by a
couple but like who in your life is
allowing you
like who's where like i mean obviously
where you're getting your news whatever
but
it's so fascinating to me but i think
that what we're
leaving out of this conversation and
this whole
moment is the conversation about
addiction and i know i talk about
addiction so much because i identify as
an addict and i have so much addiction
in my life
but self-righteous indignation is a true
addiction you know getting dopamine off
of sending a tweet and getting a
response and
the adrenaline of ron functions
responding to me and me pissing him off
like a lot of people crave that drama we
get adrenaline every night doing
stand-up
like for a lot of people sending a dm to
you
and getting a response that's that's
their madison square garden
you know and and it's it's really sick
and i try to
stay judgmental about it but i also try
to stay back and just go
how are you getting i don't understand
how you're getting pleasure out of this
but but
adrenaline makes dopamine like what are
we gonna do moving forward just knowing
this is our human nature and the way
we're wired as people like we used to
sit around the roman coliseum and watch
people just get torn apart like we are
inherently a very savage species even
though we sort of have to
stand in line and and be nice to each
other at coffee shops but like as soon
as
we're behind a computer it's all of a
sudden you know when there's anonymity
this is why i call you ho roger
[Laughter]
it wasn't at the core of it with your
savages
savages waiting in line at the grocery
store
it's so true it is so
true i actually think i have more shit
on my desk than rogan does
by some weird miracle um but
because i i was always trying to figure
out like this this binary thinking
terror management this is so horrible
no i cannot say anything god damn it all
right i'm gonna start talking about
gavin newsom let's get to the avenues
fuck that guy um but uh uh
you know but i i do like sarah silverman
used to have this
i don't know if she still does it at
this joke about um
pro-life people and how
much they care about babies the irony is
like
if we're protesting pro-choice in
pro-life right next to each other we're
actually
the same person you just have the wrong
info
you know what i mean like you want to go
out and say babies like so would i if a
baby was being murdered like i you know
but we just have different definitions
or whatever
so the irony is like it's just we
actually have so much in common
we're just operating under different
facts yeah i mean that's
crazy to think about find out though um
when we can go back and travel right
like that's
when you're on twitter it feels so
isolated and feels so
like oh people are thinking but then you
go out like one of my favorites
performed
fayetteville alabama or uh arc fable
arkansas
are um what's the place in isla
huntsville huntsville oh yeah yeah the
dome
the stardom i don't remember the name
but i love the city yeah because then
you go really go like oh fuck
actually america's really fun sometimes
where you go to huntsville you're like
all these
people and i'm sure there's issues i'm
sure there's racism and all these things
but like it's a lot more of this
togetherness than we see and then
um you know everything out hear is just
all isolated isolated and
and fighting against each other and i've
just never been
i could never get into that i've always
been like hey if you're on
whatever side of the box you're on
you're holding up the fucking box
yeah so why are you what are you doing
but i think we all it's like our
fundamental human need and tell me if
i'm wrong because you just
i i see you as like an expert in like
mental health like
is our that's not true i know but here's
what i'll say
no one's an expert in mental like it's
if you talk about it a lot and ask a lot
of questions you're an expert like to me
i've heard some things on your podcast
that are more incisive and and eloquent
and
have helped me look at myself in
different ways and
have compassion for other people uh more
than any therapist i've talked to or
programmer just because you're asking
the right questions
and you're fearless about talking about
things that are uncomfortable or
you know especially that i haven't seen
a lot of men say you know
really um i don't want to say brave i
hate calling people brave it's like when
you call
a woman brave it basically just means
like they look old and they're not
wearing makeup
open i'm just open to it yeah and it's
so um
the op it's so uh badass in a way you
know because it's like the one
thing i think a lot of men are afraid to
talk about is their feelings and like
that there's something just so
um you know just cool about it and um
and all my the guys that i date i we
listen to in the car and show them like
this
is cool this is funny like this isn't
bitch
you know um yeah i mean to me it's
always opposite the other way is a super
bitch
like that's so bitch i'm not going to
tell you about my feelings like you're
going to be like i don't have feelings
you can't hurt my feelings i don't have
any
it's like all right you little bitch all
right for real
the most badass shit you can say is i'm
scared
yeah i'm insecure you hurt my feelings i
don't feel comfortable right now
like i don't i feel safe yeah just
saying that's the best strength
that's uh from a young age things from
my mom and stuff was just like
to me true strength is like not going
like you can't hurt me
it's it's going oh you hurt me
that did hurt and guess what i'm still
going to be loving
i'm still going to be open i'm still
going to um
come out there and expect nice things to
happen to me
even though you hurt me that's strong to
me
as opposed to being like oh i got hurt
once it's all
usually just one guy got hurt by one
girl when he was a fucking teen
and then he's like well now i just don't
feel any feelings and fuck these bitches
and i don't talk about anything
and it's just like you're a weak fucking
child fucking grow up and be an adult
and say what fucking bothers you
yeah also she was a bitch yeah
women are kind they have for real for
real truly they will try to eat your
soul sometimes
it's just that's um that's really
fascinating to me and i i'm curious
about your strategies about how you
when to internalize someone when someone
hurts you
uh and when to not so for me i tend to
take
everything way too personally which is a
form of narcissism really
to assume that everyone's running around
trying to hurt you like it's usually by
accident
you know it's usually just sort of your
a casualty of their own insecurities or
fears or whatever and you i
spend the whole day having my feelings
hurt when i'm like hey that hurt my
feelings are like
what i wasn't even talking to you you
know i mean i make it bigger than it is
but sometimes it's good to
just find that out right yeah yeah what
are what mountains out of molehills
are we making but other times i will
dismiss
bad behavior and have denial around it
and
excuse the behavior like when do you
excuse it
and go oh they're just sick and
suffering or oh they're just in pain
oh i'm projecting and you know like how
do you
when it causes you mental or physical
harm i feel or everyone affects you
in any negative way just having
boundaries that's like
one of the biggest mantras i've found
because i used to be
just like oh i'm like oh we'll figure it
out like no one's evil
no one's in and he's like well no one
can be has to necessarily be
evil but you can no one has to be a bad
person but you can be bad for me
you know like you can be good for
somebody else you could be great for
somebody else
but you're bad for me and so i can't
have you around
and that's where the boundary is for me
is just
knowing even in all relationships i have
i just try to keep people
at a distance to where i can love you
and in a healthy kind of love and and uh
that's so interesting but it also helps
me to know like
because i tend to go like you make me
feel this way you you're doing this or
you're doing this and then
i find that i can really figure out if
someone's healthy for me not based on
what they're doing
because i can be very dysmorphic and i
can hallucinate and i can project and i
can
minimize and dramatize and rationalize
it's more now i'm at a point where i
know
okay i know if someone's bad for me
based on how i'm behaving
am i making myself small am i being
anxious am i complimenting them or am
i giving them gifts that they don't need
am i buying them expensive candles like
their behavior i'll never be able to
really decipher because i'm just too
my vision's too cloudy but if i start
like feeling separated
or trying to not be funny do they make
you feel shit like that or they make you
feel
open and they make am i trying to make
you feel okay to be naked
like you know that's one thing with my
wife one thing because she was super hot
so i was thinking but
she when i when she looked at me i'm
like she made me feel like i'm
fucking you know the hardest thing to
make you feel insecure
yeah one tool that does work for me
which because i really struggled with my
default being at war with people
um i did and i got a tattoo it's a white
tattoo so a lot of people can see it
right here is i just say i love you to
someone
every like i go through the hallway in
the comedy store and anyway i love you
like i have to say it in my head over
and over again um and i also find myself
if someone hurts my feelings
i try to ask them three questions about
themselves
i know it's a contrary action i have to
do
just to get to know them a little better
like where are you from like
are your parents still together and then
i'll learn something that's like okay
got it you're you're hurt too her people
hurt people got it and i'll just i'll be
able to detach
and not take it personally because it's
not about me this person didn't go out
of their way
like i'm gonna go hurt whitney today
they hurt a lot of people you know
um through their life that seems like
you looked so
deep into it i'd like i just people i
had one
just recently where uh someone just
brought me
this like job opportunity and then
like the the company was like uh
like i didn't respond in a club like i
just said yeah and then i went about my
business
and then they were like we haven't been
able to hold you in a couple days you
don't seem interested
and so then i reached out to my friend
and i was like well do you know about
this he's like oh yeah they were
i was like why didn't you tell me that
they were having issues about it and
then i was like
so then i was just like i just let it go
for me but i go you know what i just had
to let you know i feel like if you were
actually my friend
you would have falled for me a little
bit you would have told them how
professional i am
you would have told them uh how good how
much of a value
i am because they don't even know you
know like they think that i'm just some
they thought i was just some twitch
streamer they don't know i'm on movies
and tv shows and shit you know
and so it's like in my head they wanted
you so bad they offered it to you and
then followed up three days later
that's what i would think you know but
they didn't and so it was just the thing
of being like i just want to let you
know this hurt my feelings and i feel
like
i'm like you probably don't feel the
same way but are you thinking and he was
like that was like oh you know i just
didn't think about it or
why when would i have told you and i was
just like i just know like how i look at
friendship that if someone was like oh
we're having a problem with your friend
i would be like
text right yeah you know just because
like it was me and you or something
i'd be like what's going on well i would
do i'd go hey dude just fyi we haven't
heard back like
if you don't want to do it it's fine but
just like let us know i don't want
you know but also it's like you know on
the flip side of that is be authentic
and be yourself and if i write back yeah
and you
take it as a no what's going on with you
i don't even think i want to work with
you
yeah that's what it turned out we don't
speak the same language and we both
speak english yeah i was like you know
what i'm not enthusiastic
anymore you're right yeah you turned out
to be quite right you projected onto my
curt email which yes yes it's a yes and
i'm learning more and more as i get
older like
you can speak the same language and
completely speak different languages
like i have people in my life and it's
taken me so long to stop trying to
change the way
i am to try to get them to understand
because they're just committed to not
but when you're
you know in relationships and you're
like look i was just
you know or friendships even when you're
like look that really hurt my feelings
like oh so i'm a
bitch and you're like you didn't say
that didn't say that you said that and
we're just
not able to communicate for whatever
reason well usually what that is right
is that
the immediate reaction to like oh i did
something wrong and i don't want to feel
like i did something wrong
so i'm going to turn it around right
away and it's not you know you gotta
um you know it's something that you on a
lesser extent i mean my wife still
struggle with of just knowing how to
communicate with each other when we're
both triggered about you're always
staring at her ass while she's trying to
communicate with you
often or i'm not paying attention around
and say it to me one of our main things
you know i'm a messy i'm a messy person
and how so like with you just leave shit
everywhere at least
a trail where's your job to clean it up
what's the problem
that's a confusion and then you know she
would just take it
personally and i'd be like you know like
i'm no i'm not like hey you're my slave
and you gotta pick up after me
i just literally don't think about this
yeah and so if you have a problem with
just go hair
go pick it up because you know she would
just leave it for a couple days
and then be like i'd leave it for more
days
[Applause]
she well i've done that a lot where you
kind of like leave it there to be like
oh he'll eventually get to it i'm not i
don't want to set the precedent that i'm
going to clean it up but then it doesn't
work
you're like i'm expecting him to read my
mind in that moment
um okay so i always ask this to
especially comedians that are in
super healthy relationships because
there are let's be honest you know kind
of few
just few healthy relationships i think
in general but um
why her i know why but why her
i've met her i i get why but you know
when um
you know i think a big part of this
podcast is we talk about red flags we
talk about why things work and
and uh when someone's in a successful
relationship i just want to mine
every piece of wisdom they have and uh
why when was the moment you're like it's
her she always seemed to really be
attracted
to me when i was kind and she always
um just didn't like it when i wasn't
and i was like that is someone i want to
be around
is someone who makes me
want to work better be the best version
of myself and
encourages the best parts of me you know
and believes in me and truly like you
know she'll
get work with my diet for me and stuff
like that because she's like you are
she's like yeah you're a leading man
you're a fucking lean man and they're
gonna figure it they'll figure it out i
know it you know it they'll figure it
like i picked you
yeah yeah i could have been with anyone
yes
really truly no it she'll tell me
because we're getting arguments like
sometimes i'll forget and i'll get like
that and i go oh you only want you like
the
you like the act you like the you don't
like the part of me that's weird and
and gets anxious and uh you know can fly
off the handle a little bit
and then she's like no she's like if i
wanted to be she's the only thing i
could have gotten another fucking
comedian
you don't think dayton cook's not
outside my house right now
that is fascinating what are some red
flags
that that are that are absolute bottom
lines for you absolutely not
um if you want to think about it for a
second let me know okay i mean i could
just talk about things that come up
i just don't like it when people aren't
you know classic once people aren't
crying to like if you're on a date and
people are kind of the waist desk that's
a huge
that's like the number one red flag for
me i went on my first vacation with the
guy that i'm dating right now this past
weekend
and not only because this was the first
date we've ever been on
we've it's the first time we've been out
to dinner because of the pandemic but
we've been dating for eight months
so i've never seen him you know and uh
and not only was he so kind like would
say
oh hey janine how are you so like not
only so kind but also
flirted with the older waitresses which
i love just like you look beautiful
too like i just it made me so it was
such a relief i was like this is like so
much more important than sex to me it's
so much
more than anything else and not only
that but also flirting
with the older ones yeah it's so hot
yeah you got a little competition yeah
yeah you could win
like okay i wasn't feeling that
threatened kind of
everything threatens me but it was like
to to flirt with the older ones and sort
of like
you know be charming it was just so cool
to watch no
i mean i killed her after but it was you
know sweet
he like made her day you know that's a
great one
people are super i mean these are things
that i learned by going through them
like you know i had a girl
show up like drunk to the date and i was
like this is not ideal
not ideal yeah exactly you think it and
sometimes you think i was gonna say
too that was uh
no certainly not on first aid and and
people who just
don't expect to be treated nice you run
into that a lot in l.a i think
especially
when i was dating in my 30s and stuff
you just ran into people who are just
always like even my wife we have we tell
the story like i took i think it was our
third date and i just took her to this
restaurant
and i was like oh it's going well and i
go like i think this date's going well
i'm just going to come out and ask it
and she just was like
and i was like do you want to go on
another date
i just i it just depends on if we're
going to split it or not everything
on another day though yeah but she was
like no i thought for sure you're gonna
be like well it's our third date we
gotta go have sex or
i haven't went on oh go on another date
and not sleep together yeah i was just
like i'm having fun
let's have another day you know um
which you know there's time for i'm like
we're just hanging out on that side but
if
i'm looking for a relationship looking
for a person to be with
like yeah let's just chill and if
someone's always
expecting to i mean um the other thing
i know some people don't like her
coachella views but
i worked with vanessa hudgins on
powerless and that was one thing i took
from her when i worked because i
remember opening door for her
on set just because like you know that's
why we do and just the way she walked
through
she said thank you she said thing but
she never broke stride
she never once expected that door not to
open for her oh that yeah
yeah you know yeah and i like i like
that in a woman
i like that when a woman ex be like you
you will treat me nicely
and i think there's this this struggle i
see with the youngins about like i'll
open my own drawer i can open my no
i know you can open it no one thinks
you're handicapped and you're not
capable of opening a door that's not
because i used to kind of be like that
like i'm gonna pay for everything i'm
gonna do i like like i'm an independent
woman and it's sort of like no
true power means you can allow you can
receive love you can receive
acts of service and not be keeping score
in your head
yeah because i always was so suspicious
that i would interpret them as a
manipulation and if you're strong i'm
weak or you're implying that i can't do
something
which is coming from a place of like
total insecurity and and as you're
talking about um
uh this it it reminds me of a piece of
advice that i loved
that i heard which is that insecure
people are dangerous
and i think sometimes our instinct with
insecure people is to pity them feel bad
for them
but someone else's insecurity is their
problem to solve
if you're in there's something about
insecurity where people think i'm
insecure i'm insecure it's like
go fix it if you're so insecure go to
therapy go to
the you know aaa elena there's so many
opportunities to fix this
but it's no one else's fault and it's
your problem to solve just because you
admitted it doesn't mean we all have to
accommodate it
oh yeah no i'm very you know sensitive
and and
if you're dealing with mental issues or
illness of any type i'm always
in your corner but i've never been
thinking of like i will never let
someone's
issues allow give them an excuse to harm
me yeah
like you can fill however you want to
feel you can be insecure you can be
whatever
but if you if that is what's causing you
to harm me
then i gotta cut you out until you
figure yourself out i'm not gonna
hang around and wait for you to figure
this out that's not
what i'm here for and frankly me being
here is probably enabling it and making
it worse for you but i think that i've
been thinking about this a lot
because i've had my feelings heard a lot
recently and i've seen a lot of people
on social media do stuff that's like
upset me or pissed me off or whatever
and
i'm really trying to delineate you know
the difference between
intention and impact and the guy that
i'm dating
does not let me get away with anything
it's very annoying
but he always says to me like because
i'm like well that's not what i meant
he's like it doesn't matter
you're 38 years old your intention
doesn't really matter here your impact
matters the first couple i like him he
seems good fuck it's such a nightmare
yeah he um yeah he's like cut that shit
out like he doesn't let anything slide
and like i mean i'll because i
look my dad was a lawyer like you know
we're comics like we can pretty much get
anything over on anyone
we can manipulate we can win we can
charm
this we can charm we can beguile we can
bully
we can say something an observation
about you will
that will change the way you see
yourself forever
you know and this is the first
relationship i think i've been in where
as soon as we're arguing we're on the
same side
and it's like i'm not fighting with you
i'm fighting for you and this is the
first time i've been in a relationship
where i just pipe bite my tongue
and it's like if i win we both lose like
i even when i
when i win i don't feel good i feel bad
you know in
relationships before i was like i won
yes you were out to destroy he respects
me or like i'm you know and it's like
wait that is
so sick and unhealthy that is such a uh
a damaging
philosophy but um he'll all just do
something and he's like
does that work for you like he literally
would just be like are you oh you're
doing that thing where you go under
generalization and then you use your
arms to try to destroy he's like okay
let me know when you're done like he
just has no uh
patience for it and doesn't entertain it
yeah and my wife and i are very much the
same in that
and um i think because we just have
similar backgrounds and been through
similar traumas
to where like we just notice each
other's triggers and
she'll and so be for a lot of other
people like you know i think i would
have these red flags
like oh you know you you showed me
something so i'm going and then my wife
would be like
no you're this isn't about me you're
freaking out about something else
um if it's hysterical it's historical
yeah you go figure it out you calm down
and you talk to me later and
and um and i try to do that with her
sometimes she don't listen to that
but
[Laughter]
i'm so sorry that we now have to take a
break in this delightful
train of joy charm and love
frankly sexual chemistry let's be honest
everyone can feel it
um to talk about better help that's why
i need it because the sexual chemistry
yeah i would say
because if i want to land a man like ron
punches i'm gonna have to get my shit
together
you're gonna need better help is there
something interfering with your
happiness
don't even ask because the answer is yes
and it's me
[Laughter]
you can start communicating with a
better health counselor in less than 48
hours
that's insane can i tell you something
by the time i'm like i need a therapist
like calling to schedule and they're
like you can come in two weeks like i've
already
made the bad decision i've already
snorted the adderall
i've already you know wired four hundred
dollars
to that woman who said she was my
long-lost sister i've already made the
bad
choice it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online so go to
betterhelp.com
it'll be on your time wherever you are
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and good for you listeners get ten
percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
whitney that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash whitney also please record
your session and send it to me so i can
listen because i
probably have that problem too yeah
that's not hipaa loves that
here's a list of things i'm not doing
leaving my house getting my own
groceries
or items from restaurants um and talking
to anyone so doordash works out great
for me
because they keep me alive i'm looking
through my doordash orders these are my
completed orders
and i am not ashamed to say that i order
from doordash uh
sometimes three times a day well they
have over 300 000 partners in the u.s
puerto rico canada and australia and you
can support your neighborhood go-to's as
well
or your favorite chains like popeye's
chipotle or cheesecake factory by the
way you can also order flowers and
cupcakes on here
you can order pop-outs because that's
like that's key uh yeah with the
cheesecake factory i know how would you
feel about that cheesecake factory is
important
that's our special place am i allowed to
say this are we gonna lose the sponsor
a lot of the doordash people are fucking
hot
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 percent off and zero delivery
hey take off that mask let me see that
pretty smile for a limited time our
listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
whitney2021
that's 25 off a 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app and enter
code whitney2021
don't forget that's codewhitney2021 for
25 off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply it's also
just nice to have someone to talk to
these days
so true i think that was another moment
when i realized that she was gonna be my
wife is when
she was still living in canada she was
in vancouver
and i went to go visit her on her
birthday we got into some dumb argument
for some reason
i like stormed out of the hotel and i
went
to the grocery store to go get her some
fruit and birthday candles
because i knew she didn't want cake and
i was like i'm gonna stick this fruit in
this mango
like this and make her realize that she
fucked up because i love her and that
was him i'm
so mad i'm gonna show this bitch how
much i love her
i hate her so much that i'm gonna spend
three hours
trying to carve i mean mangoes are hard
as shit it was difficult
how do you feel about change a woman
gently suggesting or changing a man's
fashion
or hair choices
[Laughter]
is that toxic and sick like i radically
accept
the person but do you have to radically
accept the person's hair
i think you can make suggestions but you
can't force them to change the
and i think uh what if they're going to
bro no man
wants you to dress them no man wants you
to like maybe you can suggest hair
things
or you can be like look at this brand i
like
this maybe even show the model and be
like look at this model i like this
baby i think you will even look better
than this guy and this type of style
that could work in their brain but like
i think
like one of the things that was not
working when i was married in my 20s was
that like
my wife was dressing me and it wasn't
like to make me look
nice she was putting me in floral prints
and shits and be like
i don't want you to go out there looking
attractive you know
is there anything that she does that x's
did
that it isn't isn't it isn't annoying
when she does it
um because i have this theory that we
have a lot of this like black and white
thinking about like i hate it when a guy
does this i hate it when a guy does this
or i hate it when a girl does this
but then i'm also like you know if it's
the right person that might actually
not bother you so much um
it would be more a general thing of like
figuring out what's worked
for us and i always felt like anything
we talked about this um or very early
and the relationship where i was just
like
um i need to have someone who's like
i'm a comedian i need someone else who's
like a rock star
who's also got just as much going on as
me and
that i can't have someone who is like
staying home or doing like that
and like that was my mindset before and
my it's not like my wife is like he'll
stay at home and do nothing
which is that's not even the thing yeah
if you're staying at home you're doing a
shit ton
yeah um but my wife is great like she i
call it like she's
a great writer she's really funny she
knows a lot about comedy
but she's like truly like the ultimate
like supporter like she's really good at
making
all of my stuff easier as far as like
the things i was like well she'll lay
out clothes for me or
she'll know like oh you have you're
closed not close she bought for you
exactly well you have cordon on monday
you have this on thursday so you need to
have this outfit here we need to have
this dry clean here
and those are all things i thought i
would hate those are all things i'd be
like go get your own business leave me
alone but with her i'm just like oh man
you really take you're making it so easy
for me you're taking care of me
but you're making me realize this is
something like it's about motives so
it's like
one girl can put stuff out for you and
be like i'm trying to control you i'm
keeping score
you owe me and then someone else can do
it for fun and for free
and it's really just all about motives
like you can do kind things for people
and either try to control them or have
them owe you from a codependent
standpoint like that was my whole thing
for a long time i was like but i'm being
nice
i'm helping you i just got you all these
gifts it's like well none of it is worth
it if there's strings attached
and if your motive is actually to
control me and change me oh that's the
thing that
my wife and i talk about all the time
though i go like i gotta always remind
her if we get into these things like oh
look i love everything you do for me i
appreciate it very much
i hope that's the number one thing i
need you to do for me is always be kind
to me be sweet to me talk to me sweetly
because i'm very sensitive and so like
you could stop
cooking you could stop doing all that
other stuff if you're just kind and
sweet to me
you know so if you're feeling like this
is a obligation
just stop yeah because i need you to do
it with that sense of love in your heart
and you know and in general she does you
know because she just was like
you you know she makes me you know
in a place where like a lot of people
are either like oh you're lazy you do
this your pothead
you're literally the busiest person i
know i know if people
if people look they know you know but a
lot of people don't look
and she never you also don't bra you're
not like a braggy person either yeah you
know
like look at this look at that yeah like
i'll just watch a tv show and you'll be
on it i'm like what
like he didn't post about that he didn't
like brag about it and tell everyone you
know what i mean it's just sort of
um it's cool thank you yeah
this is what it is now unless it's like
you know chop 420 on discovery plus
that's one that i post and get excited
because i'm like this is my
show you know but tell me how that came
about you pitched it you
no i didn't pick nothing to you it came
to me
you actually emailed them back that's a
first yeah you finally figured out how
to follow up on an email thank god your
assistant is here
but uh i went on chopped and went on the
regular job just
it all usually comes from me trying to
step outside of regular shit
you know like one thing i learned early
in comedy it was like
wow it's very competitive here you know
it's a little less competitive
going on a cooking show and being the
funniest person when there's like
when i'm with musicians yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know and so
are like instead of being like i want to
fight to be seen on comedy center or
fight to be seen on netflix or whatever
it's just like
let me pop up all these different food
places doing these different things
because i want to that's just kind of
what i grew up loving yeah you know
god forbid us do something that's fun
and we're not like competing with a
bunch of comics on a game show
exactly and ruining our friendships by
trying to beat them i mean that was
always painting with at midnight i was
just like i don't want to be i don't
you'd be mad at me i'm here to win it
was sort of like the one
that like the one i became a comedian so
i didn't have to compete with other
people for points
yeah well i mean i am competitive so i
loved doing that
but cause you always win yeah that was
part of it
i know that show was fun for you because
you would always crush it so i went on
chopped i sucked at it i don't even know
how to cook
so it was just like a fun experience
where i learned and i didn't know how
real it was like they don't like a lot
of those things are fake
you know and they're like well here we
got this thing for you but they were
like no you better make it
um and i just bombed out of it the first
round but i was like you know my sweet
self
and fun and stuff and they always
remembered me
and then they were had this idea for
having a spin-off that added cannabis to
it and they were like
who could we get that lowe's weed and
it's funny and then we know
and they will like let's get rid of who
tests well yeah it's not that easy
it's not that it's it's true you also
have to uh check a lot of boxes
in terms of focus groups and people have
to really like you
which is kind of my problem well it's
not your fault that was you
we've talked about this they stuffed you
down people's throats and there wasn't
they couldn't have any other reaction
but to
be like whoa hold up you know if i
always say like if i saw a bunch of
billboards
with a girl like like wagging her finger
at the camera
called like amanda i would do 40 minutes
of jokes about it
i mean i would you know that was
everyone's reaction was like
i agree with you that was
awful and it was at a time when i didn't
know like you know um i i didn't
understand that
even when you get a job that you're
allowed to protect your taste or it was
i just thought like
you're a whore and you do it all these
people in suits know way more than you
do
about they know math and science and and
i have to be nice to them
so that i'll be able to stay on the air
i didn't realize that your leverage was
really your numbers and your testing i
thought my leverage was like this
lawyer or this guy that went to school
for advertising who's now a comedy
executive like
i have to get his approval so i was like
dressed in a banana costume i thought
look but remember remember
remember when you thought comedy club
owners and managers were the most
important people in the world
remember that feeling yes and then you
start getting on shows and stuff and you
go
oh bitch you don't matter i could i
could tell you to go fuck yourself and
you won't book me as long as i feel this
room
that's right that's exactly right it
used to be
please headline me before i can sell
tickets you know
and then uh and now it's like this is my
travel budget this is like
like like 70s prices you know value jet
prices like
they haven't even you know so it's yeah
it's it's it's knowing your power and
knowing your leverage
and also just like a magical thing i
didn't i didn't know how to say no
because i thought
no meant you're not gonna like me i'm a
bitch i'm you know shrill i'm with all
these things because i always
i already felt like i was on thin ice
like i already you know had the imposter
syndrome of like i don't deserve this or
all that
shit and um but yeah i mean i remember
being
on the shoot for like the billboards
and just you know dancing like someone
like threw me a beach ball
and i was like you know there's like a a
whole table of props and you know and
and i grabbed the beach ball and i'm
holding a bitch and i just look at this
beach ball and i was like what is it
what am i i'm like carrot
i'm like you know and i just remember it
was like an out-of-body
dissociative experience where it's just
like i just need to do what these people
say
which is the opposite of comedy you know
following your instincts and what got
you to where you are
i feel like we're kind of finally to
place with comedians maybe a little bit
where it's
not like you're super funny doing that
now play a fireman
you know he still happens yeah that's
still like um
you know just dealing with that as far
as like them like oh do you know my name
or do you know my voice you know like
fascinating and so a lot of places they
just hire me because they know my name
and then
they want to make me do something else
and i'm trying to transition
away from doing stuff like that just
because it doesn't
feel good and i did a couple of those i
remember doing a show on cbs just
because i was like
i want to say i did every network you
know and then i would come home every
day and i talked to my wife or it was my
fiancee at the time
or just my girlfriend at the time and i
just be like i don't feel funny
i go like i can't tell if i'm funny i
don't know if i'm doing a good job
they tell me i am but i i don't know i
can't feel it
usually i can feel it yeah they're
professional liars
uh professional pretenders uh so
everybody's brilliant
so like you know like what's going on
and so um and it's just really
still trying to go back to that place
where like at the end of the day yeah i
need to feed my son i need to pay these
bills
but i need this to be fucking fun if
it's not fun if i'm not
engaged in it i'm going to fucking suck
you know
and i like being a positive and i even i
had this kind of
it was actually the cartridge i needed
to hear is this gay
in denver who has reviewed my like the
first time i did comedy there
he reviewed me and he was like he did a
couple of jokes from the twitter that he
wrote on tweets and i was just like
this guy fucking why are you fucking but
then i
learned to like him because i was like
this guy pays attention he's obsessed
with you what do you mean like but not
just me like with all the comedy that he
saw in denver you know he would pay
attention
yeah and he would see it and when he
would write whenever he wrote positive
reviews about things it would be
about i was like oh yeah i thought i
should lean in this direction you know
and i had a conversation with him
recently promoting this chop 420 and he
was like
man i really like seeing this for you
because i can tell
how much fun you're having i can tell
that you're engaged
he's like i've been seeing the couple he
was honest he's like i watch a couple of
things and i can tell you're like you're
just doing them and i was like
i needed to hear that because i've been
noticing that
and so i needed that to tell me and give
me a reason to stop doing those things
because i was just like
same thing like oh i have to do it i
have to do it because if i say
no they won't want me but if if i keep
saying yes i'm going to get weird
okay you know i'm going to get weird and
bitter it's you know it's interesting
when we talk about comedy so much
because i'm always like oh god should we
be talking about it's so inside baseball
and all we're doing is talking about
comedy but it's a metaphor for everyone
i think it's like everyone's got the
same i think comedian sometimes we're
like our job is so special like it's
like everyone
has a version of this whether you're a
waitress or you know lawyer you have to
speak in front of people you know or
whatever you do
um and um you know to
be able to do the job but it not feel
like an obligation
is such a hard thing you know and
um because you have to get that flow
state on stage like the audience feels
when you're
reciting it when you're wrote when
you're just like you know
being a robot about it and it'll happen
when if i do like two shows a night the
first one i'm in it and then the second
one i'm kind of phoning it in and i'm
not getting the reaction i want it's
like oh they feel it like
like 70 of this is just energy and it's
just sort of like connection with the
crowd
and you can't check out because i mean
you can i can fully do a set
and be totally somewhere else you know
and like
pull it off but there's no like
connection to the audience you know
that's the difference between like the
electricity yeah that used to be my
um that's what i would do if it wasn't
going well i'd like all right i'm just
going to check out
i'm going to tell my jokes and i'll
check out and i'll i'll catch
get the check at the end of the night
and then i realized like um i think it
was watching
the gary shanlen documentary about being
you know mindful on stage
where i was just like you know what fuck
that you know if if that's happening
then my thing is gonna be i'm gonna make
sure
no matter what i like this set i had fun
if no one else if everybody else fucking
leaves mm-hmm
as long as i at the end of the night
were like oh i had fun i made myself
laugh
i thought of something different i me i
said something
brave that i thought people would hate
me for
or something then i had fun and i
loved it no matter it's more than like
if if you you know there's a
tree sting or whatever like we're
killing it at some point killing
is easy if you know the tricks and you
know um
you know not with every audience
obviously but like but if you know your
audience you know your trace you can
just start
killing it yeah yeah no but it's
different to be like oh i'm growing i'm
being mindful
i'm um learning myself i'm i'm getting
just as much out of this as they i'm
actually giving them more because i'm in
the moment
and like you say i don't think that is
comedy related that's any
type of like job when you start checking
out and you start
just being like well i'm just working
for the weekend and you're just like
well motherfucker
like most of the days are the week you
know like you should have fun during the
fucking week
how has doing podcasts changed your live
shows um i think it's just made me more
uh patient like that's probably been it
more patient more mindful
more open to finding things it was
actually really helpful for
for the chop show um i cuz i thought it
was just like okay i'll tell jokes
and i will use hosting skills um but
then i ended up having using a lot of
podcasting skills because
um you know these shows you know they
want stories they want
things and i have to be like oh how can
i ask the right question
to get them to talk to me about what
it's been like for them to not
work in their restaurant during the
whole pandemic or
or this guy one guy hadn't seen his
father in 12 years
how can i a stranger who they just met
while they're also trying to compete for
ten thousand dollars how can i ask them
that question that doesn't make them go
hey you know what i'm busy fuck you
you know yes so i had to start to be
like
you know just figure that out and i
think the podcasting of like leaning in
of like no of just finding things
whether it's like something on their
clothes or something where i'm like oh
like tell me about this and
then get to like because like my
engineering things was like they told me
my ear like oh
that's about the debt tell me about your
dad you know
and that won't work no no no no but yeah
you got to lube them up a bit
guys um and i'm also curious about your
audiences like
do they expect something different from
you when you tour
based on hearing you you know be so
vulnerable and talk about mental health
and
like you know do you feel like you owe
them any of that
when you perform live um
i don't know no really yet um i think
some of it is still me trying to mix a
bit of it
because i do like i l i think my podcast
is my
like i don't not the most profitable
thing i do but it's definitely my
favorite thing to do is my wife's
favorite thing that i do
and i like to stay home
well she just goes you're actually like
you're funny funny is great she was like
but people
will write and be like you know i mean
like all of you changed my life
you know i shared you that message i got
after your episode where a lady was like
i had to get out of this relationship
and i knew i needed to get out
but and it took me listening to the
podcast and listening to
you talk to whitney to be like oh i
can't take this and things like that are
like so fulfilling or even more than
like any
like standing ovation or anything like
that so i'm trying to like
portray a little bit more of that on
stage but also
never get to the point where i'm like oh
we're here to just this is your safe
space and we're here to like
no i'm going to tell i'm also probably
going to say a racist joke or a sexist
joke or
something that is you might
yeah and to me those are fun if you like
you know me you know my heart
yes you know my heart that's it you know
like anthony jasmine right you know like
if you know my heart
that's what me that's why i can call you
horror you know and it's also like
we're going on this roller coaster ride
together you know this is like we're
saying a bunch of stuff we don't
necessarily mean a lot of is like
thought exercise and i guess i just
i get a little conflicted because i'm so
codependent because i you know i was
reluctant to do
a podcast for so long because i just i
just don't think i'm that like i'm just
i
i'm i would love some tips um but
i it's it's it's very hard i don't feel
like i'm particularly
um there yet in terms of of what i want
it to
be and maybe that's just what a podcast
is it evolves as you evolve and as you
you know
it's just weird because you're learning
in public that your first episode
everybody hears and it's like wait i've
never done this before you know and
you're learning
um in front of everyone and making
mistakes in front of everyone instead of
like making all the most you know
comedy we can practice in private and
then we show you the final product well
that's actually even one of the things
about that when you said the whitney
thing in the
um beach ball because i think i had some
similar like lessons but they were all
like smaller scales so i was like oh i'm
glad i could learn this
now as opposed to when i'm on like some
big
nbc show so in some ways i feel like you
know i don't feel bad you're rich
but like i'm sorry that that was you
having to go not from that shop
um but uh uh from the two bro girl
[Laughter]
the um that's fascinating because um uh
shandling actually said to me one time
um you know
and he said at the right time the right
way right when i was able to receive it
because i never would have believed it i
think if anyone else has said it to me
he said he wants you know you can never
make it too late as a comic
the only damage you can do is making it
too early getting seen too early
and i was absolutely seen too early when
young women come to me and they're like
how come i'm not getting the spot how
come i'm not on fallon how come i don't
know it's like
i promise you like take it from me like
i think i got a couple opportunities i
didn't deserve just because i was a girl
or whatever they needed a girl in the
lineup
i was seen by montreal i was just seen
before i was ready
you know before i really had a point of
view before i was really comfortable on
stage when i was still trying to make
the comics in the back of the room laugh
or when i was still
apologetic and being too dirty for no
reason just because i was trying to
neuter myself or
you know make the open mic you know
laugh or whatever be the darkest
you know because that's a lot of times
what happens at the comic store 2am is
just who's the darkest
um who's the the grossest who's the you
know tells like the
craziest rape joke or whatever and i
feel like i definitely
got a lot of stuff before i was ready
before i knew who i was and before
certainly before i was able to uh be a
boss whatever that means i had no idea
how to be a leader i had no idea i was
so concerned with people liking me that
i was unclear and that's the worst thing
you can do in any work situation
you know i love that i love that yeah
and then you change it later and they're
like you just lied and it's like no i
just didn't want you to
not like me and then everyone's like
well we just had to do more work because
you
are trying we we know you like us you
hired us like we don't we're adults
we can handle it it's more efficient
yeah we can handle it and i was so
um with people that worked on the show i
was like well whatever you want like
what do you think and they were just
like just tell me
like we just want to get out by eight
the nicest thing you can do is just get
us out by eight be decisive and be clear
and i couldn't be decisive
because i was like trying to you know
make everybody like me and make them
feel involved and empowered and there's
a way to do that without wasting their
time and vacillating and
you know being wishy-washy and so i
didn't have those tools yet like make
sure you have your
your mental health together before you
decide to
you know or get big opportunities like
you know um
it's a war it's a fucking war i've been
trying to make a
show about my son and i for like four or
five years
two coming up on two years with this
iteration and um yeah i learned a lot of
those lessons i think the first one
i was so happy that i was like mad at
the time i didn't get picked up
but i was also like just i'm happy to
get money to fail yeah that's fine
yeah that's a success in itself um but i
was doing a lot of that like oh well
what do you want how do you want
to do this like the writing partner
cause i'm like oh i've never written a
show like
before so i should listen to you and
what i've been liking them now whether
it gets picked up or not
um is that it's really been me leading
and being like this is the story i want
to tell it's about instincts
i'm about right experience yeah even
getting arguments with people in hell in
the right way where they were like
well he needs to have a passion
and what if he's an artist a drawer and
i go look i can't draw for shit yeah and
i go
and then even my manager would be like
well you know it's a show and
it can be not you know i go i go yes i
get
that but listen to this everything that
you guys have responded positively
to has been true so how about we just
stick with that yeah
instead of faking it now fascinating and
also it's
you know i'm always stuck between
respecting people with experience but
also going
you know you have experience in making a
bunch of shows that
were really relevant before but the
world's changed and actually
the most valuable uh person in the room
is maybe the youngest freshest point of
view or the most authentic point of view
and i always struggle with that
you know because i put writers that have
done a lot of stuff on pedestals but i'm
also like oh you've learned all these
bad habits
um you know you know how to just get a
script done like everything you're
pitching was really good
when you did it on will and grace but
you know how do we
break the how do we do something
different you know so yeah to me i'm
it's the same thing happens in um
like like medicine or especially
veterinary medicine um just because i'm
dating a
that um is that somebody knows yes
this seems right i mean he's also
31 i'm 38. who cares i know i know it's
kind of
perfect yeah no it's it's weirdly
perfect and i it's
it makes no sense but also he was under
30 then i had trouble
you know because i'm like no way but
like 31
that's a guy who might be like i want to
you know get my shit together
dude yeah i mean older where there's
something um
you know i think obviously as a vet not
a 31 year old comic
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean he's what
nobody tells you about
doc they're like data doctor data vet
they don't tell you about they have
student loans until they're in their 40s
oh i know my sister's a doctor
oh wow yeah they don't start making
money until they're in their 40s and 50s
yeah my mom was leaving she was like oh
your sister just paid off her student
loans
she's like i'm so happy for her she's
like i just never felt it was
fair that you had your money and and you
didn't have student loans i'm like what
the fuck you mean it's not fair
you think it was fair when she was
graduating college and you were calling
me
every night going well what's going on
with your life
well you didn't give a shit if you
weren't like oh you're smart then
you weren't like oh good good for you
for not having student loans then
also guess what comedy's the best
medicine
yeah so i'm actually a doctor yeah i'm
the real doctor
this is a joke about how i was more
powerful than her even though she was a
doctor but then kovac really took the
wind out of that sale
people weren't responding well to that
anymore
i was just like the biggest i like
canceled and canceled coming after the
nurses
cancel but but sometimes in veterinary
medicine and medicine in general the
older someone is
the less they know about the new
technology and the new stuff and they're
operating on some old software so i
think we have a lot of ageism both ways
you know but there's a lot of ageism
against young people when it's like
you know especially writers and stuff
where everyone's like oh you know you
lived this but we know more about how to
do it
and it's just sort of like how can you
know more about my life
my life than i do just get out of the
way just kidding that's my thing like
that's my comedy
it's not like i fake my comedy here's
the good news you i'll do all the work
you can go home it too like it's also
this thing of like i
it's my experience like i'll do all the
work you know but when ego gets involved
and when someone's like a show runner
they feel like they have to
there's this thing that comedians like
have to be babysat
that they have to sort of be um wrangled
or something because we're too like
unpredictable and
or something and you know i think that's
kind of changing a little bit
yeah collaboration you know i've met
some water people people
i mean it doesn't matter it will either
get made or not but
um development with people effects now
and like just talking another way
it never makes me feel like she's like
oh we got to change this to fit into our
motor thing it's more like
she'll make me look at the world bigger
should make me pull it out of like just
my
out of just my story and go like okay
well what's the world view on this
and i go like oh okay well that's great
i love these notes helpful notes
that's not we're not rooting for this
character because a lot of executives
just say what they already heard
and i and i noticed in the uh in this
business a lot
that when something's successful
everyone wants to replicate the thing
that was successful right
but um like after bridesmaids came out
everyone was like
calling like can you make another
bridesmaids can you make the next
bridesmaid and how many
who was your workaholics take yeah and
it's like
don't replicate the thing that was made
replicate the fact that it was original
idea
so i say so much it seems so easy but i
know it's hard
but that's not what people didn't
respond to it because it was that people
respond to it because it was a real
world
that they got invited to that's what
people respond to with
all those type of shows and then they go
in and they lean
all the way in that direction when it is
just like hey
just tell that authentic story people
will find it if it's true
it will ring a bell to people and they
will find it and that's what
i've been lucky with the development
people have been helpful and
but um i learned so many of those same
lessons and
trying to find a writing partner for
this because i would meet with people
who have written on shows or who have
been on
big shows and i'm like excited to meet
them and stuff like that and they're
telling me like oh this will never work
as a show
or this oh this is too dark or and then
it took me a point where going like oh
you know
unless it's like i and i've met people
who've made empires
i mean i know bill lawrence i know
fucking people who i knew the people
the lady who made chopped you know i
know people who make
empires and those are different those
are few and far between and they kind of
have visionaries but sometimes you just
know how to make the shit you made
yeah you know how to make the one thing
you made and that's
it and that's fine there's nothing wrong
with that but that doesn't mean you can
tell me
you know what i'm doing and i'm talking
about you the lady who made the new
adventures of old christine
you suck
look i'm not known
for having the most sexually appealing
personality on the planet
you know i have come to the point in my
life where i have accepted the fact
that if i utter
one word during sex a man will lose down
all over america
i fully support use these roman wipes if
you need them because i don't have time
to
to uh to meet with you i don't have time
to uh
try your dick like a snake trying to
yeah
your dick into doing what it should be
doing but maybe it isn't because you
watched too much porn 10 years ago
give the gift of boners roman is
discreet you have no
shame in this anymore yeah they
prescribe it it goes right to your door
you don't have to worry about walking in
and talking to some other professional
about your little pee
pee someone prescribes you what you need
so maybe it's uh cause it's not one side
it's all it's not just for it's like
dicks go to gibroman.com
whitney now you'll get 15 off your first
month it's really time to take care of
your ed
and remember get started today and
you'll save 15 on your first
order of ed treatment that's a treat for
everyone
june shine is like it's like the
champagne of kombucha
oh look the champagne of kombucha
they're so pretty
it's just the perfect buzz where you're
not an idiot you're not
sleeping with anyone's husband you can
still function properly
but it just like takes the anxiety
i feel no headache the next day i don't
feel dehydrated and just like
no migraines it's just a goddamn treat
it feels luxurious it feels like
something i shouldn't be allowed to have
and
also uh probiotics probiotics gluten
free
i am probiotics yes they use green tea
and honey opposed to black tea and sugar
and they are committed to being 100
carbon neutral they donate 1
of all sales to environmental nonprofit
we've worked out an exclusive deal for
good for you podcast listeners receive
20 off plus free shipping site wide
i recommend trying one of their best
selling variety packs it's a great way
to try all their delicious flavors
go to juneshine.com to use code whitney
at checkout to claim this deal
that's g-u-n-e-s-h-i-n-e and shine
like moonshine but it's june shine
just click yeah we got oh
can also be found in over 10 000 stores
across the country including whole foods
safeway
kroger and dude i
there's this new freedom in podcasting
where you guys created a very dangerous
breed of comedians
by pissing us off on sitcoms because now
we have podcasts and we don't need you
anymore
and we can make money without you and
we're just i mean i was just saying to
myself and i was like i'm making more
money from doing
two at home gigs than i am for these two
fucking a movie and a show that i'm
guessing on yeah and i'm like oh you
guys
you expected us to keep your secrets
forever because you thought that we were
never going to have another platform
besides you
and it just was a grave mistake but um
but i also think um and i know i have to
let you go soon i promise i will
i'm just enjoying okay good are you
happy okay i always yeah i like you i
always feel like i'm keeping
people getting i'll let you know okay
yes you will it's so insulting
to assume someone won't just go i gotta
go yeah
now you know who did do that so well
with maria bamford i had her on my
podcast
and i was just about to let her go so i
was like it's fine i
respect your time but then she just goes
i just gotta let you know i told my
husband i'd have dent we'd have dinner
at this time so i have to go
and i was like oh i love your boundaries
oh i would have just ruined the
relationship
yeah i did it like the i was did bert
crusher's podcast for five hours and my
dude had made dinner and i just
he's still pissed uh i need the approval
of bert who i've known for
15 years but uh but i also i think that
um i'm i'm now seeing so clearly now
that i've been able to step away a
little bit or just have had
so many things go wrong after you know
just having like a pilot every year that
is too dark or everyone just kind of
wants multi camps it comes from me and
if i try to do something dark they're
like don't think that's what anyone
wants to see from me or
too edgy or whatever or um the woman's
not likable i get that a lot i tried to
do a pilot that was
about a woman that suddenly started
making more money than the guy in the
relationship and it shifted the power
dynamic and how he felt emasculating him
was trying to restore the power dynamic
and it's
funny screwed everything up and it was
sort of based on when i first
you know started getting successful
everyone everyone thinks you have a
billion dollars
the second you book a job you know it
takes a while to get paid you know
whatever
and so i found myself minima i thought
there was a lot of comedy and how i was
like
you know i finally got a nice car but i
dated guy and i'd park it
around the street so he didn't see it
and i take an uber or like to the car
so he never saw that i drove you know
stuff like that um and uh
and we had this like amazing chemistry
but then one time he came over to my old
house he lived in you know
an apartment and all of a sudden he was
like are those both speakers like he was
just like
how much do you own this house how many
like and then we like never hooked up
again like it made me way less
attractive to him
so it was about sort of that stuff and
they were like oh this would never
happen like this isn't relatable
like no woman has ever made more money
than a man like
it was like so insulting to men and
women like that's the other thing sexism
usually is like it's just as sexist to
the man
but i think there's there's there's so
much um a lot of hollywood writers and
producers um
hate their viewers like they think
they're
so dumb they can't handle a challenging
show
they think they don't want to watch
something smart i mean i can't tell you
how many rooms i've been in where it's
like oh yeah but like
the average person like joe blow isn't
gonna get this and it's like
you think everyone's just so dumb if
they're not a hollywood writer
which is a self-fulfilling prophecy
right like you you're
you're contributing to a dumb culture by
creating by
saying that you know by by living that
lifestyle and
as art that's what you're taught is the
right to your audience's utmost
intelligence to believe that they're
smarter than you
yes love it and a lot of you know i
don't want to get specific about the
college that
a lot of these writers have gone to but
um it is a lot of like
we're smart and people that are either
blue collar or working class
are dumb and we need to just do this
dumb shit and they don't get it you know
it's just like that drives me
insane and it is so like disrespectful i
think
yeah to our audience even like and
they've been less so with the fx but
originally
like a lot of it is about you know just
me getting sole custody of my son and
being
custody of a kid with autism and
and to do that i had to like have this
character of his mom that
like leaves and um isn't around and is
doing things and they were
there was so much flush back of like we
can't show my mom that leaves we can't
shoot that that doesn't happen
and then i go like no that does happen
it happens to so many people
it happened to me yeah the exception can
be the like what are we doing
and i know so many there's so many women
i know who have such a
complicated um history and feelings
around mother's day because of
of their relationships with their mom
and and it's never brought up it's not
it's always like
no moms are perfect and dads are stupid
and now we just wanna be like
no i wanna show this story about a dad
who had to become good
yeah because the mom wasn't around the
mom wanted to be fun
i think it was amy sherman palladino who
does maisel and did gilmore girls i
think who said like
you know like things will be equal in
hollywood not when there's the payment
or more
like same amount of women and men are
writing the same shows it's when women
can be assholes too and uh
can behave like men or men have
traditionally done and because i argue
that
a lot of the most people attack these
shows for being sexist towards women
i mean the women the men are dumb and
the women are super smart and super
perfect which is like
you know neither is the case yeah it's
when you can to me
we will reach a great point where i can
watch a black show that doesn't have to
be
about a guy who either got out of jail
or or slavery related a black
trauma stroke struggle thing if
uh if there's a woman comedian that
looks like jay london
and she's also funny and famous jay
london you guys google jay london
fantastic i'm gonna look like jayla if i
kept doing weed animals i would
i would have i was very close to looking
like jay london just with blue hair
instead of brown therefore i was wearing
overalls the other day i mean i'm
how dare you but you know what i mean
like that's always been
okay yeah you can be like i was talking
about this with my wife the other day
but
she can look like that or she can look
like that and it's not the a story in
every episode he just
happens to look like that or the
character just happens to be black and
not every story is about that's not the
only thing interesting about the person
yeah just getting in the way because um
like my wife were talking about we were
listening to some podcasts and the guy
was like
and we talked about his favorite
comedians favorite female comedians
and it was all like it was like you and
nikki glazer
and it was like it was all we were
laughing we go like oh
no these are all like your list is
basically here's the comedians i'd fuck
yeah it's 100
[Laughter]
you know and i just really like to get
to a point
thank you yeah of course whereas like
but we're very okay with zach
galifianakis
with the you know i'm not putting people
down i'm just saying like it's
socially acceptable to be a schlubby
dude but like
not necessarily for women all the time
with the thing and even so with guys
more and more refinement i'm wearing
spanx right now
[Laughter]
i stopped wearing spanx when i got fake
tits so it's like a whack-a-mole
situation
well i'll get there yeah i want to
follow up with a couple things because i
get so excited and i and i jump around i
do want to talk about the tarot cards
okay is this something you do on your
own or you have someone do it with you
uh now something do people do with me
before
um when i was my first marriage my wife
was in the tarot cards and stuff
and um i that's how i got into it and it
was actually very helpful my first tarot
reading
was actually the one the first times
people someone told me they're like oh
you're going to work in entertainment
you're going to work in com i was
working at a bank at that time you know
and they and i was just like oh you i
didn't even believe in it i was like
you know skeptic and they were just like
oh you're waiting around for somebody to
come save you
and and and tell you you're funny and
stuff like but it seems
and it wasn't again like he said the way
they said it wasn't like
i see this i see that it was they were
mad
they read my shit and they were like
jealous
you know they were like oh your life's
fine you're fine
i'm obsessed with that you're fine just
stop
go don't do it stop wasting my time
like there's people that need help
around here yeah it was a bit like that
and um you know because i was on the
oregon coast and shit so it was very
easy to get into
metaphysical shit um so and then when i
got divorced i
um i kind of that was one of the things
where i was like i still want to
keep this part of me i don't necessarily
you can get so addicted and frozen on
making decisions
because i'm like oh is this the right
decision flip and so i stopped reading
for myself
but if there is like because you can
interpret it
like it's like the way you can kind of
read any horoscope and make it apply to
you if you really want to
exactly or you can like well this must
mean this because i want it to mean this
um but now um i have a lady named danny
uh who will read for me on occasionally
and um last one was like recently during
the pandemic there was like a job i got
a
um audition and for some multi-camps to
come and
i was like i don't want to do it but
then i didn't have anything to do so i
was like i'll just do it i'll just do
the audition i'll have fun
and then because i was having fun of
course they were like you know worse
we want you to do the call back and i
was like you know what thank you so much
i appreciate that i don't want to gum up
the works i actually was just doing it
for fun
i don't want to i don't want the job i
was just trying to waste your time i was
just trying to distract myself in
practice
i told them no i told them no from the
get-go you know and they came back
around
and then i did the audition and they
were like dude
i would producers no never means no yeah
and then when i told them i don't want
to do the call back and they were like
well what if we just offered it to you
and then i was like oh and i was
counting the money
and i was like i don't know what my next
fucking um
stand-up date will be and it was like
you know i don't like the money in
general but i was like
it was like it was almost a million
dollars i was going to turn down you
know
guaranteed money and i was like
uh i want my own tarot card reader named
danny
but again i'm working on my shit for my
son and if i
was if i take that as you know i can't
do both
so i had to be like well
do i take this guarantee almost million
dollars
or do i keep pushing the thing that i
really love and i feel is my calling
but i've thought other things with my
calling and i was fucking wrong
so um and i just read with her and she
was just
it was very much like you could take it
but you're gonna hate it you're not
gonna have fun
she's like she's like just believe in
yourself just figure it out you'll be
fine
so i turned it down and um
the show came out it doesn't look good
because you're not in it i mean it is
your career and life and and personal
life is really not defined by what you
say yes to about
what you say no to and i look at all the
things that like broke my heart
that didn't happen and i look back and
i'm like oh my god rejection is god's
protection like whether you believe in
god or not you know
i love a good rhyme just it just is you
know these slogans like
and i know sometimes they sound like
platitudes or you know whatever
but they do work because at a time when
your brain is over complicating
something
when you just keep it simple and say
something super simple
it just is it it is how you get to the
solution because my brain can just
like you were saying the mouse and the
maze or whatever it is it's just like
um say what you mean me would you say
don't say it mean i say that all the
time on this podcast i know but it's
like
at times when i want to overcomplicate
things i have to get justice and i have
to set a good example and i can't i have
to it's just like say what you mean
like these when you have a complicated
brain when your brain's on fire
sometimes just little platitudes do the
trick you know halt
hungry angry lonely tired like if you're
angry and upset just halt are you hungry
are you angry are you lonely or you're
tired if you're not making any decisions
that's what i do i never make any
decision based off the fact that i'm
tired in the moment
you know because i used to i'd be like
oh i don't know i'm so tired and so i'm
not going to want to do that
two weeks from now you know 100 percent
in like and like if it's a stair close
historical i think that's like an
alliteration it's like a little mind
trick but it kind of works and helps me
remember you know so
i love those little things even though
they might sound like reductionists and
you guys are probably getting annoyed by
me
um but i want to talk about psychics for
a second because
i you with tarot cards is kind of like
me was psych i used to go to psychic
and i don't know if i even believe in
psychics i think we're all so
deeply psychic and intuitive but we've
really disconnected from our source
and we've learned to doubt ourselves and
and go well you're being irrational
you're being emotional you're being
judgmental like we really
i know i have a strong intuition i've
always done there's one thing my mom
said about me like mom was an abusive
relationship for like over a decade and
she's just like
she's like i should have just she's like
you had the you and your sister just had
intuition from the moment you met him
you're like this guy's not a good guy
this isn't a good person i can't explain
why i can't write an essay about why
but i just doesn't pass the smell test
and i think we dim our superpowers a lot
no you don't listen to those intuitions
when you don't follow
that's what is getting you as far as
you've gotten you know
and um i think for me a lot of it's been
through like getting back into exercise
getting back in the diet
that um allows me because a lot of it is
just being
toxified you know that ruins our
intuition from us i'm a firm believer in
that you know
when you're on stage and you're truly
killing and you're kind of in that
middle zone in that flow state
where you're not in any time you know
when you're like
when you're in the present future and
the past when you're
like saying something in the moment when
you're clocking the audience for your
next joke or for
the moment and you're analyzing how that
joke went in the past
you kind of didn't kind of learn that
like oh there's more here you know um i
can i don't know how to explain that
unless you know
but yeah yeah you know and i think that
we're such a verbal species and and
that's why i like
like working with animals so much
because um it's so non-verbal and it's
about like energy exchange and i think
we're so um
uh you know negative about that like i
feel this from this person like
you know has been a stereotype as you're
like dumb and ditzy or something or like
do too much ayahuasca or whatever
but um the reason i uh i'm going to this
is is that
when i went to the psychic you know i
was like oh my god this woman is so
psychic and i'm sure she is and you know
i'm not
i'm sure some are in some are like some
comedians are funny some aren't funny
yeah you know everyone in their job you
know there's always a spectrum of how
uh qualified people are for any job i'm
sure so um but this woman i realized
that it was like
the way i was saying something whether
she was psychic or not
she could tell everything she needed to
know by the way i was saying something
so you know she'd be like so what's
going on with um
uh what do you want to know about your
love life and i'd be like you know i
like i i really like this guy jason but
like i don't think it's
like i just don't know if we should be
together or not like i already said
everything and then she's like it's not
a right fit and i'm like just like
you just started cringing and bending
over and like
going into a super dubious state about
this person like you just told me
everything i need to know
you know so it was like a kind of
interesting lesson um
and and and i went to her whether she
was psychic or not who knows
um but because she was just like a
mirror to my own
like i knew it all i knew everything in
my cells
but i needed someone to tell me what i
already knew that's my favorite
knowledge
usually that's why i find myself it's
not like something i gain
from reading a book or learn watching
thing or i mean i love traveling
but i find like my favorite knowledge is
some of the things
that you kind of unlock within yourself
that was always there
something that was there from before you
were born and you're like oh
this is i think that's what like when i
truly feel like i'm getting better at
comedy and sometimes
the comedy story has been great for that
because just because of the things you
talked about it'll be like how dark it
can be
when i'm like oh if i can go out there
and just still be fucking me
and i don't have to change who i am and
whether it kills or not doesn't matter
i'm just going to be
me and get and that used to be my
favorite thing is to show the comedy
store
and i'd watch a couple before especially
if it was like real broly comics yeah
and i'd watch the audience and i'd see
the guys like this
and i see ladies kind of like checked
out and then i'd
do my set and like halfway through i'd
see it you know
not that i'd want that but i see the
reverse start to happen i see ladies
perk up
and be like oh i kind of like this and i
see guys being like what the fuck is
this
yeah and i was like i like this i like
you don't know what this is i'm changing
this for you
and it makes me happy i just think yeah
following your intuition
and believing it is very important to
just follow your gut and i think
we are often taught to get away from
that but it's the best thing that can
serve us it's so it's
um unless you're just falling you're
just fearful for fear's sake
but you know it's there to protect you
is there to guide you and when
when people are telling you to get away
from that just because they want to
guide you they want to control you you
know
and the idea is that people it's also
our job to be brave encourage justin to
say things no one else will say or make
arguments no one else will make as a
thought exercise just to like
get us out of our you know heard sheep
mentality but it's also our job to be
super original
it's to to change the energy you know um
in the room and
when people like that's a weird take and
it's like yeah that's i hope so i hope
no one's had this take before you know
i the last thing i wanted someone to
come up to me and go like yeah you're
just like this other you remind me of
this part whenever someone says that
you're just like fuck
yeah you know or this reminds me of that
person and you know i never want to be
fighting for the best version of the
same joke
why it was so well put so well put
and you know in this when i was thinking
about your show um
i meant to uh bring up the chris rock
quote of the more specific you are the
more universal you are
actually you know and i always forget
that cause like ah everyone's doing
airplane jokes food okay i gotta do the
airplane joke food
you know or joke or whatever and then
it's just like no it's like everyone
else is doing that i didn't think anyone
wanted to hear about like
what it was like to be a woman or like
you know and and there's still things
that i'm like no one wants to hear about
that
and it's like that's probably the thing
you should talk about you know
yeah so i lean lean into is either like
oh that embarrasses me i don't want to
talk about well now you got to talk
about that's the thing you got to talk
about
talk about it can i ask you what shows
um you like or what you were watching in
quarantine shows movies anything
of course you just i told you already 90
day fiance
pro wrestling did you discover anything
new
like did you re-watch i re-watched it we
watched breaking bad that was fun
i think my favorite things i watch in
quarantine um i really
like i just like going through and
watching old sitcoms with my wife so
like we watched all the living single
and that was really good watching
tomorrow and you know because she's so
canadian and white
that it's fun to like be like well you
haven't seen this or that or
something she's seen martin i don't
think she's
living single i have uh this might
whatever
i still think martin's the best to come
ever i think it is
not i mean you the funniest right kind
of the funniest it might be right it's
the funniest
purpose because i'm thinking favorite
sorry funniest yeah it probably is the
funniest and i also
argue ellen uh the sitcom is great was
was
a very very good and going back and
watching it again you're like oh there's
some shit here that i missed the first
time i watched it i like ellen i like
grace under fire
i'm a big end to old christine
no i don't like the show either
nbc's witness um
but yeah i went back and watched a
couple movies that didn't hold up
like did you go back back and watch in
the old movies we were like oh we're not
big
movie people we'll watch multiple
episodes of 90 day fiance
or watch three hours of wrestling but a
movie a commitment that
because i'm not going because i knew it
on show i can pull out at 20 minutes 30
minutes
i got to just on a movie if i don't
watch it till the end
hey i don't know i mean you could i
didn't turn it off
but then i'm gonna miss it i don't know
we tried we watched um i mean our
favorite again
i would say that bad trip fucking like
classic
instant questions instant classic you
know it's weird i feel like it took a
second for that to i feel like i
remember when i was shooting and i was
like what is taking this so long to come
out
and uh and i guess the pandemic or
whatever yeah
perfect it's like what is taking you so
long oh right this is like dying from a
deadly virus it's a beautiful movie and
it's such a
um we both know eric it's such a like
that's what we were talking about we're
like wow
that he and it's probably because you
know they've worked together for so long
uh but that's his voice that's his voice
is
this beautiful kind chaos of like
my favorite thing from the opening of
the movie when he's busted through the
house
and he stops to open the door for the
lady and i go i just look over my wife
and i go that's
fucking arrogant
and i was like this movie is amazing and
to me
like watching a movie you know that one
obviously hits
succeeds at every attempt you know but
even when i see something that doesn't
resonate with me like i've see a couple
movies that are like winning oscars and
stuff i'm like
as long as you made the movie you wanted
to make i like this movie
to me the definition of a successful
movie now is that the person that made
it got to make the movie
they wanted to make and watching that
with eric i was like dude you made the
you did exactly what you set out to do
you did not compromise one bit
and um that adds more joy even more joy
for me
yeah it's beautiful because i had just
been taught my wife i go i don't know
when the last time i saw a comedy movie
yeah that made me happy that made me
laugh
it didn't feel forced and cringy yeah
that wasn't like awesome studio
like like because my thing was like
here's my uh
you know my every comedy movie i've seen
in the last 10 years is just
throwing a weird object at a woman's
head
what's the weirdest thing we could hit
her in the head with
a dick that is
so funny did you see the woody allen
documentary no why would i watch that
okay
i don't understand i don't like i want
more
fucking fun black stories and stuff
instead of like oh why
you just like no let's get another white
serial killer thing
let's find out more about john wayne
gacy
that's what we need it's so true the
fuck
give me a fucking show we already know
about those motherfuckers who murder
people
i ain't murder nobody
i have a fucking viral tweet recently
zero women commented about sexual
assaults that i did
you know how rare that is in my business
give me my fucking show you're like one
of the only people
who you don't you guys don't have to
worry about like a skeleton coming out
of the closet later
you are the safest person to give
millions of dollars to right now give it
to me
but no let's do the ted bunny tapes yeah
we have 90 documentaries about you know
what zac efron wants to play him let's
make a
scripted version yeah that's what the
people want one of the most beloved
actors on the planet to play ted bunny i
kind of like ted now
let's fix ted's reputation i mean he's
had it too hard for too long they will
it is easier to get your reputation
together as a white serial killer from
the 70s and 80s
than it is as a black man pulled over
today
that's weird it's so
dark it's so sick
[Laughter]
um i love you so much i love you too
that did feel like a good exit
i used so much more to say but i don't
know if i'm like so any favorite
jams any favorites like i don't i think
it's
a wrap like i don't really i don't feel
like we can go back to small talk
now it's just kind of i uh just like
hate myself
yeah i'm just ready uh to go cry um
your podcast is uh getting better
everyone like it is so healing it is so
um medicinal
it's like free medicine nice getting
better
your voice is so soothing it's i even
like listening to you
uh thank the people that help support
the podcast i don't think when you're
like jenny in michigan uh
hope you're having a great day it's just
like it's just like it's did you ever
hear
prairie home or it's it's mr rogers in a
way
yes it is it's on purpose yes hundred
percent
oh so that i'm not a genius for no you
know
you're the only person who bring it up
so you kind of you're still for sure yes
i won yeah no that's part of my real
another conversation
i was like oh you're he's like you're
just kind of like you're a mr rogers who
curses and smokes weed
and that's okay which was my only
problem with mr watchers as a kid
can you curse and smoke weed and wear
cooler clothes and not be like white
but mixed with like a little prairie
home companion
you know and you also something that is
so fun for me to listen to
is when um you'll be like i was gonna
ask you a question i forgot what it was
anyway um which that to me is someone
walking the walk
of what they're saying like you'll just
be like oh i forgot what i was gonna say
and i'm like when you say that like you
just i was just listening to an
interview and you did that you're like i
just lost my train of thought anyway so
what do you think about this
and i'm just like oh god it gives me
permission to be able to say stuff like
that
like you're walking the walk and you're
modeling the behavior and not just
analyzing and talking about it yeah well
it's um it was truly
about like actually starting to listen
instead of being like
oh i have this one question and then
when you're done with that answer
i have this question ready and so it
started to be like okay i have
one question and then i'll listen and if
it makes me
remember my question great if it made me
lose my train of thought that's fine
i'll say that and then i'll go
where your your answer led me as opposed
of me
trying to be like you know i'm not a
fucking liar king risk me rest in peace
i'm not anything i'm just like oh i can
listen and i'll follow along
and i think it's um abandon the plan if
something else comes along and i
i i feel like i have this plan i have
questions written and i'm like okay so
you just said something super
interesting can you stop because i have
a question
that i wrote four days ago i can't
remember you know what i mean like i
feel like i had to stick to some script
and listening to you going like oh no
just allow it to go where it's gonna go
and stop trying to control it
uh and like scripted and um get all your
super interesting questions that you
know like it just
listening to your podcast is just a
dream thank you i really
like it i mean i really like just
talking to comedians and
actors or whoever wrestlers uh about
um just the constant grind of things and
the constant search are getting better
and
how it's like very similar in so many
ways and that
uh nobody ever feels like they made it
at any point you know
and to to find that out and to talk to
these people
and get all this free advice is very
helpful for me
uh because i take a lot of that advice
you know and then
just be able to give it to other people
is just kind of like you said i'm trying
to do things
that i would have wanted you know
because when i wanted to make a podcast
i was like well there's a million
fucking podcasts
i'm not gonna go out there i hate
topical so i'm not
going to fucking talk about the week and
review
um i don't want to have a partner i
don't want you know i was like i'll just
talk about the things i did with my son
like every morning with my son get up to
school i wake him up and i go
you're strong you're kind you're brave
go out there and be a good guy and i was
like oh like i never talk like that in
comedy like let me
bring that out the people and you know i
just thought like
and it happened where i was like oh my
comedian friends will make fun of me
they think
or they'll think i'm trying to like
become some
self-help guru or some shit and it's
just like no i just
these are the things i like talking
about these are things i talk about at
home these things talk about with my
wife
you can talk about what my real friends
you know
and part of the reason i think to me
part of the reason i was so scared to do
a podcast
i was like like i'll just feel like i'm
bombing for three like i always feel
like i'm bombing for three hours but
it's not that's
my shit because i only think i'm
valuable when i'm entertaining
or useful like that's i oh i'm the
person that goes to parties like do you
need help
do me and i'll just start cleaning up
because i'm like i'm only valuable if
i'm useful or
have a gift or am being do you need
water i got no but i got double story i
got love enough
yeah that's one of my um when i get
maybe like a younger comedian on my
podcast
and i'll know like like because you know
it's just a different format so i'm like
no we're just going to talk and and but
sometimes they'll come in and they'll be
like
joke ready joke and if i don't and i'll
i will purposely
not give them anything i won't laugh and
i'll just be like okay
well tell me more about this you know
what's going on with you that makes you
think you need to
tell jokes with me and my producer
because they're uncomfortable
yeah why are you i go or i'll just
straight up and go like well you know i
know you're deflecting right now but i
really do want to know the answer to
this
question thank god i didn't go in your
podcast sooner than last year
that's why i rescheduled so many times
but that was
another thing with my wife as well is
that i did that i
um i would like try to
joke around or like be like like oh i
need to show you that i'm funny or
i think one of our biggest first fights
is like
she was telling me some story and i was
like and i just go oh that's boring
and she was like what and i was like oh
i'm
joking i'm like i was trying to turn it
around and she's like well she's like
look like
i don't need you to entertain me i'm
with you because i like being with you
and if i want you to listen to something
just listen you don't have to
turn it into a joke you don't have to uh
uh
look for a hole to poke and do it you
can just be here
that's what i loved about finding this
is like
well here's another avenue whether it's
stand-up podcasting or whatever where i
can
truly be me and it will attract the
people who it'll attract
and that's one thing i love about my
podcast is that i'll get people like man
i love it if i'm great and i'll get
people who'll go like
i thought this was accordions fucking
shit i hated your fucking affirmations
but i happened to stumble across one on
instagram on my
back on a i was having a bad day and it
hit me and i go
oh now i get it now i see the value in
this
and now i'm fucking now i'm listening
every week
and i'm like okay that's great that's
what i'm here for i'm not here for
everybody
i'm not here to even i don't fucking
give a fuck about everybody
i'm here to find the people that need
this
i love you i love you i always end these
very awkwardly
that's fine you i feel like have a very
elegant way that you end your shows
thank you i love you like glad that you
listen that makes me happy it really is
like
one of the few podcasts that doesn't
like stress me out you know i don't feel
like anyone's getting hurt i don't feel
like anyone's being made fun of i don't
feel like there's any low-hanging fruit
like there's no like
like that's you know that was
unnecessary oh that was not about me
like it's just like a lot of podcasts
are just sort of like
um um funny and great but sometimes they
make
they bring out they reinforce some old
patterns and beliefs
and yours like i never i never listened
to it
and i'm a worse person after just saying
i'm never like oh yeah i can fucking
just slam you know it makes me be like
oh god i gotta evolve
like it makes me in a good way get
inspired
to like dig into the nooks and crannies
and be like yeah i still have
there's still more work to do in that
area or like yeah we all do
yeah we all do it's constant but then
what if you did and then you'd
be like time to die yeah like it just
makes me like
i get excited to get better and instead
of daunted because i have so much work
to do it's like no i like i can do this
you know yeah more opportunities not
burden more opportunities and you also
speak in a way that gives me vocabulary
to be able to say it to other people
and like in a way that isn't shitty you
know i find myself just being like
you're a fucking mess it finds those
being like look like
every now and then you can when you're
hurt or insecure like it helps me uh
stay patient you know thank you it's a
beautiful compliment
i love you i love you too you're a good
friend and good person
thank you i'm gonna receive that i
didn't argue with you good
why would you i have some stuff for your
wife nice um
and uh uh don't write elephants that's
always how i end this
and anything else you want to say say it
what's chop 420
watch the golden arm the movie i'm in
that's also feels
good uh mary holland betsy sedero eugene
cordero oh wow
real fun people it's gonna be good and
then it's when does it come out
april 30th oh where just anywhere uh
theater isn't on demand nice
it should so i just google it i'll just
google things
and then i'll tell you what number ever
it's like what network just google it
yeah and watch chop 420 on discovery
plus
watch it so we can get the plus off that
bitch and then
[Laughter]
that is so fucking funny shit i love you
it's round punches
[Applause]